PEGI 18
you
hello everyone and welcome to this
gamescom 2015 presentation of measure
sought five phantom pain today was just
about a month left until launch we want
reveals on the specifics of developing
snakes new mother base and how you can
manage Diamond Dogs to develop new
equipment and abilities to support you
all in the field will also introduce you
to the games massively multiplayer mode
the fov system
what you see here snakes new mother Base
home of his new military force the
Diamond Dogs as you gather personnel and
resources you can expand the base which
will in turn allow Diamond Dogs to
support you in the field if you meet the
proper requirements you can issue orders
to develop various types of weapons or
items get fuel support in the form of
Intel or supply drops or first aid and
medical treatment all these support
features are enabled and managed through
the development of other base for those
who want to manage every aspect of your
army you can handpick assignments for
your various units but if you prefer you
may also leave these in the has a miller
to make assignments as he sees fit how
deeply you're involved in the day-to-day
management of the base will depend on
your personal preference and play style
in addition to the management of mother
base there are also related activities
and a few new surprises so keep on
watching
to begin we'll introduce you to the
primary sectors that correspond to the
various units on mother base then we'll
show you each sector we threw in their
operation and explain how you can expand
and level up each facility to strengthen
your various units
start bringing people in use this it's a
Fulton recovery device
all right we have our Fulton let's move
on we'll begin by giving a tour mother
base as we introduced previously can
freely walk around mother base right now
we're on the command platform the center
of your base and the heart of Diamond
Dogs by expanding this platform you can
enable more staff to join your army but
it's up to you as the player to actually
recruit the right people into your army
by locating and filtering highly skilled
personnel from the field recruits can be
called from the ranks of enemy soldiers
you manage to capture or the maybe POWs
of volunteers who are attracted to your
army through your reputation your
recruits are automatically sorted into
units that best suit their particular
abilities however players can opt to
reassign staff as they see fit since
mother base independent pain is an
actual physical location you can also
interact with the soldiers that you fold
in once they join and down develops as
you gather more staff things will get
crowded at base and a certain point
you'll reach a limit once that happens
you'll need to invest in expanding
mother base to facilitate more staff
aside from the command platform which
serves as the hub of your base you can
also build specialized platforms for
each of your units so let's give that a
try and begin by constructing an RD
platform convincing this is your base
you can choose which platforms to
prioritize along with the location of
your platforms and can customize other
elements such as color as such every
player's mother base will be unique
this is the rd platform it's connected
to the command center by a bridge and is
an example of the spoke design a mother
base this platform houses the R&D team
work around the clock to develop new
weapons and items based on your orders
the proper weapons and items are
invaluable as you proceed to the game so
it's wise to invest properly in rd new
projects will be added to the
development list based on level your R&D
teams and the actions you perform during
your missions examples include various
types of firearms along with more
powerful weapons such as missiles
and other more specialized items as well
invest in the equipment that best suits
your mission and play style
alright and it looks like it's started
to rain as we've introduced previously
the weather at mother base is dynamic as
with other environments of the game and
will change randomly
let's head downstairs and see if we
could head indoors just gave the rain
alright what you see here is Huey's
private lab it's here that he'll develop
new types of robotic technology and you
can see an example of that here but we
don't want to ruin all the surprises so
let's introduce the next team next up is
the combat unit the combat unit is
comprised of autonomous fire teams
capable of completing a variety of tasks
you can take advantage of them by
deploying them on dispatch missions if
they succeed they'll read various
rewards as outlined in the dispatch
mission list however there's also a
chance of failure so be sure to select
missions that match the team's skill
level note that certain dispatch
missions will also resonate with snakes
solo missions making things a little
easier for you all in the attached
if you feel like it you can also send
members of the combat unit out on
missions in place of snake as the
payable character this can be to your
advantage sometimes as some staff
members possess specialized skills that
are useful in the field for example
soldier with a botanist skill will have
an easier time identifying and gathering
fans and herbs it's good to keep this in
mind if you're having a hard time
fulfilling a specific mission objective
all right here we are on the support
platform this is the section of other
base that houses your support team
support team as their name implies
provides various forms of backup and
support for snake while you're out in
front lines
supply drop complete support can come in
many forms including the delivery of
supply drops containing weapons or ammo
or even vehicles
this 14 can also provide backup in the
form of airstrikes by versions and cover
fire the better your support team is the
faster they'll be able to assemble and
support you in the area of operations
applying choppers to the front lines
isn't free so be sure to keep an eye on
your GMP to keep from going to the red
level up your support team enough and
they can even develop techniques to
manipulate the weather with capabilities
such as this be able to turn the very
environment against the enemy and use it
to your advantage
now we could go on and introduce other
units within Diamond Dogs such as the
Intel team medical teams will let you
discover those capabilities in game on
your own in the meantime we'll introduce
you to some other unique features of
mother base itself
shortly
mother base is a physical location
inhabited by various characters and as
such there are various events and
encounters that you can experience
between your missions today we'll show
you just a few examples first of all
staff you've recruited to Diamond Dogs
will salute you as you approach meaning
your men face to face like this will
raise their morale it's a good idea to
periodically return to base to maintain
health morale among the staff
as you wander around mother base you may
also discover surprises from time to
time for example we're all diamonds such
as this which will add to your GNP why
the raw diamonds scattered around mother
base did they fall out from containers
we may never know for sure but it'd be a
shame to let them go to waste so be sure
to explore thoroughly
and hey it's D dog or a DD his all slot
calls him he's still a puppy here but
eventually he'll grow into an adult and
become a valuable buddy that you can
bring it to the battlefield you don't
want to touch them to know that a really
occurred to me you don't know the
awesomeness of a palm you can also
eavesdrop on conversations at mother
base from time to time but they would
feel nice right some information will be
useful some not so much let's move on
and as you can see here mother base also
features portable showers on deck so you
can quickly shower off between missions
this helps to wash away the blood and
fatigue so that you can jump back into
the field refreshed and ready for action
for goalie shower for too long and it
will actually have adverse effects on
your performance and the way that other
characters interact with you so be sure
to head back here every once in a while
wash away the stress along with smell
their shower is conveniently located
near the primary heliport on each
platform in mother base
flies buzzing around your head is never
a good sign if you make like your
hygiene for too long well expect your
staff to finally give you a hint
in certain cases maybe even lend you a
hand
snake you stink alright so we're cleaned
up and ready to go and huh looks like
someone put a poster here aside from
collectible value posters such as this
do actually have an ingame use so let's
go ahead and drive it what kind of use
exactly well we'll let you figure that
out on your own one other thing we've
hinted at previously is the ability to
train a mother base target practice
trials that is this our handy way to
familiarize yourself with new weapons
while exploring various parts of mother
base and earning your boards in the
process each area of mother base has its
own unique to target trials so
discovering all of them is half the fun
finally never forget that you're
responsible for Diamond Dogs that all of
your actions or lack of action will
affect the organization in the phantom
pain drama unfolds not just during your
missions but also between your missions
back at mother base pretty good keep
this in mind and make a conscious effort
to monitor your army we learn a lot will
do their best while you're out the
Diamond Dogs consists of soldiers from
all backgrounds an occasional confidence
may occur it's up to you as the leader
of Diamond Dogs restore order and keep
things running smoothly sure to head
back to base often and be a proper
leader here man
also keep in mind that how you grew a
mother base is up to you add personal
touches such as custom emblems or color
schemes and expand mother base in the
way that best supports your play style
as your army grows you'll eventually be
able to expand beyond mother base and
establish forward operating bases or fo
B's allowing you to support more men and
refine more resources in gameplay terms
that function as an optional online
version of mother base with all the same
customization features as your presence
online fo B's allow you to stake your
claim on the world stage every player's
FOBT will be unique and their
development will complement mother base
by following increased profit resources
and manpower to Diamond Dogs in addition
fo B's in certain geographic locations
can be used to autonomously mine
resources further accelerated
development however building in fo b
does come with certain risks boss we've
got intruders on our fov get back to
mother base as soon as you can
off
charity this is our home how can we let
this happen guess it's time to increase
security just give me the order who did
this a competitor but we don't know who
can't pin down a route to their base
but we're ready to strike back just give
us that chance boss
since fo bees are built and remote
online locations away from other base
they are susceptible to attack by rival
PFS other private forces players online
may target and attempt to steal
resources or manpower from your fo be to
minimize this threat you'll need to
implement security measures and respond
quickly to intrusions to begin with
artillery that you fold them during your
missions can be sent back in the stalled
as defenses on your fo be
note that you can remotely issue orders
to mother base while on the field by
using your I droid without heading back
to base you can imagine security
settings and develop security devices
such as UAV drones to defend your base
once development is complete you can
assign drones to patrol platforms and RF
will be and engage enemies here we can
see the security settings for each
platform you can choose to manage basic
security presets or customize all the
detailed settings in either case
security isn't free so aim to balance
defense level and cost based on your GMP
red icons indicate activities of an
intruder and you can analyze the route
and plan your defenses accordingly
however in the event of an active
intrusion you may also return to base
and handle things personally
and there we go fo b invasions can
happen at any time even during missions
the purposes of today's demo let's head
back and teach this guy a lesson do note
that while fo b does feature pvp
gameplay is different from mg 0 whereas
mg opitz groups of soldiers against one
another the action in fo b is one on one
with the primary focus being on the
massively multiplayer meta game
experience of pitting your army against
rivals from around the world okay so
here we are to rekal be the first order
of business is to locate the intruder
note we could you snake for this but for
today's demonstration you stick with are
currently selected soldier our security
team is already responding to the
intruder so let's check their status you
see the location of our security forces
and the incursion point in the bottom
right let's start by looking there
alright scoping out the area enemy
presence is one of our drones conditions
look normal times like this coordinating
with your Intel team is key so opening
up our map you see a red circle that
indicates the enemy's predicted field of
movement let's check there it looks like
something's happening here just like the
enemy has got one of our men and is
folding in the mouth so let's put a stop
to that
we couldn't save the soldier we managed
to save the container well let's head
down there and stop him before he can do
more damage all right reflex mode
indicates that one of our men has
spotted the intruder its marked now this
is our chance and it looks like our men
have them on the runs let's catch up and
finish it all right there he is that's
the intruder that said he's critically
injured some of our staff and if we
don't tend to them he may die so let's
open them out safety before moving on
and I believe this is the first time
we're showing this this is actually an
upgraded version of the poking device
that we call the wormhole extraction
device unlike a holding balloon it can't
be shot down making it much more
reliable and it looks like our drone has
entered alert mode so let's give chase
in that direction in the meantime let's
take a look at things from the enemy's
perspective now that his cover has been
blown and the defender has entered the
fray he has to be extremely careful to
help remedy the situation he's using
knock to sign in to temporarily enhance
his senses and instantly mark nearby
enemies
before laying some gas mines
meanwhile as the defender is busy
rescuing one of his comrades we see a
container floating into view and another
with the invader on top the defender
manages to shoot down the Fulton and
give chase but it turns out that the
lower level is filled with sleeping gas
and the defender is incapacitated the
container trick was a decoy while the
defenders asleep the invader is making a
run towards the center of the base and
he's now dangerously close to the goal
at which point he'll escape with a good
portion of our staff the defender will
need to act quickly to prevent that from
happening and the defender has finally
woken up but he's lost sight of the
enemy and will need to start searching
again
meanwhile the invader is using a subject
to cross the bridge security here is
light and he only has two more platforms
to go before reaching the platform the
core
taking a moment to check his I droid
you'll note the goal up ahead and yellow
and the red circle which indicates the
defenders position the defender has a
lot of ground to cover and he doesn't
know the intruders position so things
are not looking very good for the home
team moving on it looks like a defender
has installed infrared sensors in
addition to a security camera here the
invader successfully disables them but
instead of moving forward he actually
turns around and heads back in the
opposite direction
turns out that destroying the security
hardware was a ruse to lure security to
investigate as he sneaks around from the
opposite side of the prop plane the
defending side no longer has a mark on
the intruder so all we can do is respond
to threats as they evolve and once again
the intruder uses not to sign in to
confirm that the coast is clear before
moving up from the defenders point of
view you can see the soldier going to
investigate the broken camera as the
intruder continues his approach just has
a little more to go before reaching the
poor platform the defender is in pursuit
but still has no real fix on the
intruders location at this point the
invader could be anywhere so the
defender wisely climbs up in nearby
ladder to get a higher vantage point
scoping out the area there are no
immediate signs of an intruder but the
red circle on our map indicates possible
enemy activity let's take a look in that
area and it looks like one of our guys
has spotted him and wait something weird
just happened there a guard just
vanished what is going on let's rewind a
bit and see that again from the
intruders perspective looking at things
from the intruders point of view and now
see what's actually happening he's using
the hand of djibouti powerful weapon
that can pull enemies from a distance
instantly transporting them within reach
of CQC and the battlecry might sound
familiar to back to the defenders screen
you see a Fulton she successfully shoots
down and there's the intruder alright we
finally got another mark on him so don't
let him escape
hold on a sec was that a cardboard box
let's check it out all I know is a trap
smoke cardboard box and to top it off
the intruders behind the defender with
the hand of djibouti not good defenders
down and the intruder has total control
here
and there goes the defender the defender
security forces are doing the pest but
this guy is really good even dodge a
rocket it gets the platform core it's
over so let's select a different
character and redeploy as quickly as we
can first of all was like the character
choose someone whose stats look up to
the challenge along with some good
firepower
and last but not least select a good
spawn point
all right here we are ready to go
ok and the intruder is getting
dangerously close before so let's take a
shortcut and go directly to his location
remember this is the defenders home turf
so we do have the advantage in terms of
knowing layout of the base it's not
unusual to know a few shortcuts and
there's the intruder let's get it from
behind he's skilled in the firefights
let's avoid direct confrontation and set
a trap instead we'll try a decoy keep
discharging a blast of electricity nice
throw you know a couple shots to get his
attention and good job trap work
shooters down now all we need to do is
get down there and Fulton up if we can
extract him we win
and there we go these hands wins been
successful victory is ours
intruders successfully spotted and
blocked by the defending player note
that whenever the defending side IDs the
intruder the intruders m.o.b is
identified too so if you choose it's now
possible for the defender to strike back
at the intruder by infiltrating their
base and stealing back what was taken
that said you don't need to retaliate if
you don't want to as you've seen attacks
on fo bees are unpredictable and some
intruders may be extremely skilled today
we were around to counter the intruder
directly but that may not always be the
case therefore it's wise to invest
properly in security devices and guards
so they can defend your phobia when
you're not around alternatively if you
have friends online it's also possible
to request help from other players to
repel an attack every fo b is unique and
every player will have different
security settings so from the invaders
point of view it's like having an
infinite number of unique enemy
compounds to infiltrate a strategy and
care must be taken to ensure success and
as always infiltrating undetected is
your best bet rewards for infiltrating
in fo b will scale depending on how
heavily fortified the base is and on one
final note fo bees are not required you
can clear the game without them and if
you prefer to keep your experience
offline that's perfectly fine but for
players who want to accelerate
development and prove their worth to the
world by all means give it a try
in the greater scheme of things its
mother base that will have the most
impact on your success the bigger and
more powerful your mother base the
closer you'll be to achieve in your
ultimate goal that said once your base
surpasses a certain size simply moving
between platforms can become quite a
task sometimes it's nice to drive and
enjoy the scenery but when you want to
save time you can take advantage of
mother basis highly efficient cargo
delivery system simply locate a car
delivery point pack yourself in a
cardboard box and choose a destination
point the rest will be taken care of by
the Diamond Dogs Postal Service
few moments later and we've arrived at
our destination
of course each platform is also equipped
with at least one helipad so you could
choose to fly by helicopter if you
prefer honestly it feels pretty damn
good to get a bird's-eye view of the
base admire the fruits of your labor it
once in a lot so let's put on some music
for the trip in this case take on me by
aha
then let's climb aboard and choose the
destination
notice that there are platforms such as
the animal conservation platform which
are isolated and only accessible by
chopper it's here you can visit all the
various animals that you recover it
interview and raw note that there are
still many other things to explore and
mother base more teams more platforms
more options we will let you discover
those details in game to take away from
this presentation is that missions in
TPP are important a growing mother base
is every bit as important whether base
is your home expanding it opens up more
options in the field in the form of
items weapons and support
in turn during missions and recovering
resources and personnel enables diamond
dogs to grow a Fulton is your friend
when our missions make a priority to
recover personnel weapons and resources
or additional tapes like this one joy
division's level tear us apart
where was it all right so grill mother
base and when you're ready to expand
even further invest in forward operating
bases just keep in mind that fo bees
will expose you to interaction with
other players some of them will be
allies others will be enemies but for
those we truly want to stand out on the
world stage it's worth taking that risk
make Diamond Dogs as strong as it can be
and you will reap the rewards
let us know if you need supplies boss
alright and one other thing about Mother
Bates it may be your home but don't ever
let your guard down metal gear solid 5
the phantom pain will be released in
just under one month on September first
2015 thank you for watching